you
[Music]
thank you so much for the introduction
maybe just a quick raise of hands who
have used working on machine learning in
particular like building machine
learning platforms so kind of the
infrastructure for machine learning all
right so this talk is basically about
why metadata is crucial for building
such kind of machine learning pipelines
and kind of as the second hidden
pictures why do we actually need no
sequel databases for machine learning in
general so if we look at that
there are basically two parts so this is
a tldr slide if you've seen that and you
feel this is an interesting to you feel
free to leave so the first part is
basically how can we leverage
multi-model capabilities so for example
graft processing as part of a machine
learning pipeline for example for
feature engineering and the second part
is and basically is from data to data at
first we are talking about the data
itself and then the second part we
actually talked about why metadata is
important for machine learning already
in the last talk there was like this big
concept about metadata where we could
see for example descriptions of datasets
description of our functions and if we
actually want to build production great
machine learning pipelines this is also
something super crucial this is actually
also a new open source project we just
released called Arango ml which
basically covers this as well i'm york
has already mentioned i'm the head of
engineering and machine learning at
Arango DB but prior to that i actually
built a lot of big data platforms or big
infrastructure projects over involving
twitter so i was working a lot on may
sauce which was produced by Twitter
Airbnb and other companies I've worked
on machine learning pipelines for both
finance and healthcare and this is
actually like what I going to present
today are like patterns extracted from
that previous to that I already was kind
of in the database field both of my PhD
times and then over at sa P so I was
always kind of switching back and forth
between infrastructure and databases so
I'm kind of happy that I can combine
both of that right now
all right just kind of like a big dive
into like why machine learning is taking
off so actually with tensor flows and
those tools are super easy for any of us
to actually become the superhero data
scientist and this is actually driven by
a number of factors first of all as of
today we have large data sets available
which actually help us to utilize for
example deep neural networks which just
rely on a lot of data
secondly we got the compute capabilities
available so we just got massive data
centers anyone can go to google amazon
asher and just get a lot of virtual
machines and run your machine learnings
there and we also have new techniques
and especially if it comes to like deep
neural networks and this actually
enables like any of us to just run a
jupiter notebook and come up with really
cool results for example in the area of
self-driving cars or for example also
something is things that came out last
year what I found really cool is like
deepa has kind of like a deep neural
network which can compose music very
similar to baths and it's really hard to
distinguish which is which alright if we
look at kind of what a data scientist
should be doing and this is actually
what I seen in most big companies even
if they start saying machine learning
projects they hire a data scientist and
so kind of this naive management view of
what that guy would be doing is he's
sitting there using tensorflow or
whatever other framework he's writing
this really cool code for deep bath or
self-driving cars he's training a model
obviously that model is perfect on first
side so he cuz then can hand over that
model to to the production team and we
have a working model great next problem
and start over again
unfortunately in reality this isn't the
case so this is actually from a paper by
Google and if we look at what it
actually takes to do machine learning
even at Google where I would assume they
are pretty much ahead of the curve it's
like only the small black box in the
middle is actually writing machine
learning code for data scientists all
the other stuff around is like feature
engineering data
verification taking care of
infrastructure and other things so and
this is actually also where I've seen
most data science projects or machine
learning projects fail because actually
this overhead is under undervalued and
underestimated surroundings as pure data
scientist this actually means our
superheroes a data scientist he actually
needs some sidekicks
he needs help from other personas and so
here if we especially have this data ops
engineer so the data ops engineer it's
kind of like combining the skills from
data science so he's roughly
understanding what it means to take up
of what it means to do like right
attends a flow job what's going on there
but he's also understanding what it
means in terms of like writing
distributed systems so he can actually
help to operate and also evangelize such
tools across the data scientists and so
if we now look at this picture again we
can actually divide that between our
different superheroes and/or the
sidekicks so the data scientists he can
really focus on like feature engineering
with machine learning code and crunching
the real data whereas his sidekicks they
actually take care of the infrastructure
and they also take care of kind of like
see data verification I think this
morning we also had two term data
engineer this is also going in the same
direction here all right and what we
typically end up building as part of
this is like a machine learning pipeline
so on the Left we got our data handling
then we got like our feature engineering
which means like pre-processing of data
cleaning datasets and extracting
features we're going to see what
features means in just a second with
those features I can then actually train
my model so this is actually the large
distributed part where I've run tensor
flow across different GPUs across TP use
and just burn a lot of CPU cycles as the
output we end up with models so those
models also need to be stored and
catalogued so I can actually search and
use them and then kind of the last but
probably most
Hardesty model serving so model serving
is when I actually use a model in
production to do some predictions or
classifications or other things so this
actually utilizing set model so there
are several platforms in that realm
probably tensorflow extended or short
tf-x
this is a platform around tensorflow and
it's even becoming like really central
and TF intensive flow 2.0 which was just
released a short while ago and this
actually you can see just a small part
in the middle where it says like trainer
is this is the traditional tensorflow
part and all the other parts around like
example generation schema validation and
so on this is actually helping us to
build that pipeline and then also to
serving on the other side like serving
and evaluating that model in the end the
other one is cube flow so cube flow
basically was originally tensorflow and
kubernetes but has also grown into this
large ecosystems and cube flow pipelines
is basically another way to orchestrate
orchestrate such pipelines it's kind of
it actually there's some overlap as they
even share some of the projects and I
want to go more in that direction but in
my opinion those are kind of like the
two biggest open source projects in the
realm of building machine learning
pipelines all right so as promised
how do databases fit in here if we think
about it like most of us we're where
data is really important for machine
learning especially for deep neural
networks we need a lot and also
high-quality data
so probably databases are important on
the data and streaming site here
we either have we have a mix of
structured data even relational data and
then also unstructured data of which we
fought for example store in HDFS like
images or other things the second part
where it is also crucial is kind of the
pre-processing step in data cleaning and
also feature engineering but let's take
a look what that actually
so if we even just Google like graphs
and machine learning a lot of our data
which we have is actually like a graph
data format even though we push that
into relational format but this actually
comes from the fact that we as humans we
often think about like relationships
between different entities so this kind
of question how can I combine graphs and
machine learning is a pretty active
topic at the moment and so for example
feature engineering could mean we need
to derive a feature which can be
consumed by a machine learning framework
such as tensor flow and tensor flow I
mean there's the active research area
about graph neural networks but tensor
flow itself right now has a pretty hard
time in digesting just a graph so
typically if you look at the input those
are vectors so I kind of have to
transform it into something like a
relational table so feature engineering
for example on the graph this is a movie
graph as this IMDB movie example where
we have like directors movie titles and
so on and like one feature we could
extract from this graph for example
could be like the numbers of movies made
by a specific director or by all
directors and this is exactly this kind
of like feature pre-processing where
graph databases or other databases are
super helpful if we need to extract
features which can be utilized from such
structures which cannot be understood by
a machine learning framework so kind of
this typical flow is I have my data in
some format this could also for example
be Jason graph or something else and
then I leverage for example a Rango DB
which is part of this a Wrangler amel
open-source project and then I have
something which I can fit into my neural
network and just really brief rangu DB
is an open source database which is
doing native multi models so that means
it can actually deal with graphs JSON
documents and other things it also has
the corresponding Cree capabilities so
we can do graph traversal
we can Korea like into a document or we
can even do like net natural language
queries using Arango search so as
mentioned multi-model is exactly this
capability of being able to handle
different data models so it's not
restricted to only handle handling graph
data structures or document data
structures but just imagine neo4j and
MongoDB had a kid together that would
kind of be a wrangler DB and this is
really helpful if we as data scientists
need to deal with different kinds of
input and transform that into features
here if we talk about features another
important concept also related to
databases is that actually we want to be
able to reuse them what I've seen in
real-world projects is that actually
about 60 to 70 percent of a data
scientist time is being spent on
building those features so it would
really be a waste of time and resources
not to reuse them and this is actually
why many large companies like uber or Q
flow as a project are coming up with
so-called features doors or feature
catalogs and this actually allows me to
kind of either cash cash the results of
feature engineering so if I have come up
here with my directors list I can kind
of make that persisted and also I can
make a discoverable by other data
scientist so for example imagine I'm
Airbnb I've just built my first user
model and I want to do fraud detection I
kind of can just expose that user
feature to other people who also need to
do something similar so not everyone has
to reinvent that from scratch and the
other platform which is also really a
worthwhile read if you care about
machine learning pipelines is actually
ubers Michaelangelo and they also
heavily rely on feature stores to
actually scale their data science teams
all right as mentioned kind of this next
step an active area of research is
actually graph neural network so this
means that we could actually just
leverage a grass truck
directly as input and we could kind of
skip that a feature processing step
where we have to extract entities from a
from a graph but instead just feeds a
graph directly to a neural network or
even half another graph as output of a
deep neural network but this is
currently active research but I find it
really interesting especially again
mentioning that we as humans we often
think about those relationships so it's
very natural for us to express certain
data or certain problems in terms of a
graph alright
this actually brings us to the second
part and now we are moving from the pure
data to the metadata so a challenge when
we were building such pipelines in both
finance and healthcare industry was
actually to keep track of metadata so
for example in in healthcare we were
dealing with patient data
you all know GDP R is really has strict
restrictions on how you can utilize them
so we for example wanted to be able to
trace this patient record in a data set
is impacting which models being served
in production and it basically has a
background that a user a patient might
come and actually retract C permission
for us to use his dataset so it's kind
of unclear under gdpr whether that's
impacting a model so whether a model
being trained with GDP our relevant data
again as GDP irrelevant but we at least
wanted to be able to identify all models
being impacted by this data set so if we
kind of had our first machine learning
pipeline you can already see there are a
lot of different open source projects
involved so we had some data storage in
HDFS / Google buckets we had some
Jupiter notebooks we had some tensor
flow jobs we had our model store and
then we had like our models being served
in production and each of those systems
was actually storing its own metadata so
when we wanted to go in and actually
figure out which models are being
impacted by this one patient record we
actually had to go into like five
different systems and figure out the
lineage and provenance of this patient
record and it actually also had many
other challenges we were seeing so in
general we wanted to understand the
complete provenance of a model so
understand how was it trained what
impacted that and especially in finance
this was also crucial for just and
having an audit trail so if we had to
justify this decision to deny a certain
application was done based on this in
this data set you all know with deep
neural networks it's not so easy to have
explained ability so at least we needed
to be able to say hey this model was
trained for said dataset and this is
these are all like the input variables
and transformations which we did to
derive that model so other things were
just like data scientists asked where
their scientists asked like hey I need
to improve that model what is e related
data sets
what is he related Jupiter notebooks
what are the features which have been
used so basically just get an overview
of what did it take to build that model
to train that model and what are my
steps what are the entities I need to
interact was to actually retrain that
and this is also was super helpful to
have reusable steps as mentioned this
idea of a feature catalog figuring out
hey those features there's already a
user feature available and I don't have
to build that from scratch Chris someone
else has already done that another
important thing is kind of since data
skew we observed over time so if kind of
see production careese had a different
underlying distribution compared to the
training data we actually deployed a
simple statistics a model which was just
capturing like basic distributions and
so by keeping track of the metadata by
which a model had been trained we could
also ensure that it basically the live
traffic we were seeing was having the
same dead data distribution because of
that shifts it probably means that your
model isn't really
flickable it hasn't been trained for
particularly Lisette data distribution
so that was actually an alert we were
setting so yes imagine what we build was
like a common metadata store we tried
out different solutions but basically
just all the metadata would be written
into like one common database and
probably the next question is what is
all metadata so I actually took a
description from another project and
this is again cue flow as mentioned
earlier it's basically information about
execution models datasets and other
artifacts
it's not the data sets itself it's
basically a description of the data set
this data set has been created it has
this size and it's stored here this
could for example be a very simplistic
view of the metadata for for a data set
other things we were tracking were just
kind of like the training performance
the test performance where's the models
stored and most importantly what are
kind of the relationships in between
like if we have an experiment which
model has been derived from that
experiment or vice versa this model has
been trained using this experiment and
again this is also the idea for Z of
wranger ml pipelines is open source
project to basically just have like a
common layer across different pipelines
and just have like a common store for
metadata and kind of see ideas this was
actually before I joined a Rango DB
full-time to use a Rango DB for that
it's again this multi modal idea we
talked about earlier where we can have
both a document structure and then also
graph structure in between because the
challenge we were facing we kind of
wanted to store it felt like for example
for storing the training statistics
jason was a great format because it was
kind of funny it didn't have a fixed
schema it could vary between when we
were using MX net whether we were using
tensorflow
this would kind of give that give us
different statistics so it really felt
like hey just putting that in adjacent
of
this is a great great connection but on
the other hand we needed to keep track
of the connections in between those
different entities for which a graph
database would have been a great fit and
this is basically how we arrived at a
Rango DB or is this multimodal idea
where we can combine both the document
structure and then capturing the
relationships in between in a graph and
biggest advantage we had was that is
that for example this query in the
beginning which this patient record is
impacting which models it just becomes a
grafter of traversal and we don't have
to do like manual joins it's basically
like hey which models can be reached
from this one data set the schema is
pretty much matching to what we saw
earlier so we got transformation we got
features we got notebooks model
functions experiments but probably the
best feature of all is that schema is in
quotation marks because I can actually
define my own entities and also my own
relations in between this is simply
because most machine learning pipelines
are actually kind of like custom built
and adapted to my environment so having
a fixed EEMA probably isn't matching all
different machine learning pipelines
and so it really easily allows to create
like a new type so a new collection type
which is basically like a new entity and
I can then also define relations to
other entities in that model it comes
with it's like currently a very very
basic UI which allows me to search for
example for data sets or to search for
associated metadata and it also gives me
like visualizations so if I for example
I'm the data scientist I want to figure
out what's all related to my module to
my model I can click on that and I can
basically see the graph up to a number
of steps what's related to this model or
if I'm want to see like what has been
derived from the Jupiter notebook I can
do the same
it comes with different api's and this
is probably this was one of the main
motivations so what actually happened
after we had started that project and
poured it basically everything on a
Rango DB tensorflow came up with
something similar so tenza flows as tea
effects we saw earlier they announced
this year at tensorflow
summit in Mountain View's I kind of
announced their own metadata layer so ml
M D which basically drops everything
down into super light or my sequel back
ends this is pretty involved and pretty
specific to the tensorflow ecosystem but
we were still like oh shoot this doesn't
make sense anymore but in the end we
actually saw that we had a lot of a
stand we ourselves also had needs for
kind of like other ecosystems besides
just tensorflow Chris we had other
people using just psych it for example
Chris tensorflow was just like overkill
for them so a Wrangler malahat actually
has different api's it comes as a Python
package it comes as its own HTTP API and
it also comes with like the tf-x
integrations so basically lights as
small box down here
we also are integrating in that we
haven't released that yet but we're
already testing that internally so if
you're in the tensorflow
ecosystem you can just use it as is if
you're in any other ecosystem for
example from your Jupiter Jupiter
notebook you can simply use a Python API
here just briefly mentioning as the
other projects so a lot of other
projects are currently trying to define
something similar so as mentioned there
is the tf-x metadata ml MD and we are
actually also working together with the
cue flow community of defining like
inside cue flow the notion of metadata
so this is actually where a rango ml
might end up at some point but we have
to see about that in the future but this
is kind of like showing why it's
becoming so important
curse a lot of people building such
pipelines are realizing I actually need
to keep track of some metadata to be
able to operate it and this is
addressing if we briefly go back to
those two personas we had earlier this
is actually addressing multiple of those
personas so here if we look at our
personas this is actually impacting a
number of them so this is impacting both
the data scientists as the data
scientist actually needs to be able to
look up for example which Jupiter
notebooks and how the entire pipeline is
being built but it also impacts the data
ops person Christie actually needs to
operate that pipeline and it's also for
this kind of like DevOps persona it's
equally important as DevOps persona
actually needs to account for all the
resources being used so just being able
to trace like what machines have been
used or how many computer resources have
we used for a particular build so one
thing our DevOps team always was very
keen on was tracking how many resources
are being used here in model training
and therefore it became really crucial
to keep track of this metadata all right
with that I think I have some time left
for a short demo and this is actually
why I wanted to use my own laptop maybe
first of all I said all of this is open
source and links are also in the
presentation so if we just go to a Rango
pipe all the Jupiter notebooks and
everything I'm showing is basically open
sourced here and if we look at that we
can actually leverage that with a number
of different ecosystems so the example I
have here it actually starts out being
like a standard tensorflow example let
me just run that step by step looks good
I'm in the right directory
so all of what I'm doing here is
basically standard tensorflow
how many of you have actually used any
sink besides tensor flow from the tensor
flow ecosystem any of the other
components okay
this is basically this is really useful
if we just want to see like basic data
statistics or basic distributions and as
mentioned this is also something I would
at least urge you to consider to keep
track of for your production data so if
we look at the different features and
different data distributions off data
coming in if this is shifting too much
this basically means your model might
not be applicable anymore
for that a model you have trained so and
here's this is where we actually start
utilizing a rango pipe so we just
connect and this is right now running in
the same docker container so we're just
connecting 2 rango to be running on
localhost and let's hope all of this is
running well this is just warnings as I
haven't defined haven't used a public HT
TF surfy but that looks good we
initialized to graph and now I can
actually I can actually start so I can
either convert my tensor flow units and
store them or I can actually also just
create do the same from cycle there are
also examples in the repo for that we
said we can also just look at the UI I
said it's currently it's pretty basic
but it allows me to search for example
for deployments and then if we have a
deployment we can also search for for
that model related to that deployment
and then as that please still being
improved we can basically also generate
that graph the next version I can even
click in the graph and then switch
between different models but this is
like super easy to understand for
sample if I'm a DevOps person or data
scientist and I need to understand the
provenance of my information this is
super easy to jump in here and see like
hey this has actually been trained by
this data set or we can also go the
other way around if we would have
searched for data set basically see like
from this data set we have those feature
sets derived and we have those
deployments and then experiments derived
from there just briefly switching over
to kind of the core database view I mean
in theory you can also just store that
in a relational database but certain
queries like looking up like draft
reversals they just become much harder
to express especially if I have a
flexible schema where I can introduce
like random new types and I would hope
this is connecting no live demos are
great the database is obviously running
Chris otherwise my queries would have
failed but the web UI doesn't want to
load right now wait okay then no Arango
DB web UI here we go perfect so the only
thing I wanted to show you here is
basically we got two types of
collections we got like secure
collections describing our JSON data and
then we basically which looks pretty
similar but we got like those edge
connections connecting different
entities and this actually allows us to
just create like a new collection here
so for example if I have my own secret
entity type I can simply throw that in
here and then create a new connection
type in between that potentially also
connecting it to multiple of those other
entities
all right this actually almost brings us
to the end here so in short there were
kind of like those two parts how can we
leverage no sequel databases
for for really data processing so this
is the data part and how can we then
leverage databases in general to
actually keep track of metadata which
allows us to operationalize such things
there are demos for both of them all of
this mentioned on the slider open source
projects and I think that gives us some
time for questions thank you for the
talk very interesting I found always
very difficult to document experiments
on data set and so I want to follow up
on time and I think you are solving a
real problem here and the question is
how do you go from this structure so as
far as I understand this is not
reporting the experiment results so it's
missing a layer or yeah I'm missing
something so basically how does data get
in into that system right yeah so if
you're using kind of the normal T of X
system this is basically happening
automatically for you because we are
like a data source it's called in T FX
down there so if you're in the tensor
flow ecosystem is basically just gets
dumped down there otherwise it would
basically just be a pice and call from
your notebook or if you're like not in
the Pisan ecosystem you can also do an
HTTP call to store data and also to
retrieve data so this is this kind of C
idea to have like open api's that anyone
can connect to that which is what I
heard from a number of people scans the
downside for MLM D Chris this is like
you have to write a bunch of protobufs
you have to write the protobuf code to
actually store that in there and it's
quite some effort and so kind of like
our focus was to actually have really
simple api's anyone can use and
especially like anyone can use from like
a jupiter notebook easily my question
will be regarding
comparison of runtimes that mean that as
soon as I finish the model fit is there
any metric or any way in order to
compare a different option what I've
given to the runtime that means that I
probably have used a different learning
rate and I would like to see how that
evolves yes I mean this is this was also
one of the queries compared like
performance of different model
performances as I end up with
I said dumping everything in so for
example like doing hyper parameter
optimization our data scientists were
exactly using that to like hurry all the
models kind of like coming from the same
pipeline and just compare this one field
of like train performance over the 20
hyper parameter of options they had
input it
[Music]